[Music]
in all hell let loose muse oh na
submitted by Joe Molly and rival ain't
no rival [ __ ] come in like you're
already [ __ ] man
they're submitting from the afterlife
yeah you already died you mean ghosts
habib Norma got meadow over climbed out
of the UFC Octagon it started a brawl
after his win over Conor McGregor your
knees just got lazy
is this gonna be a 20-minute article we
got what they got they were there they
were they were [ __ ] there were you
like I don't need the article cuz I was
[ __ ] there and I saw everything
what did you say you don't need a
[ __ ] study because you were there in
the presence yeah yes you're back oh
yeah yeah and you should have done on
location this is JK news reporting it
was a lie we should we did we did we
should've went out there like this is
Tiffany reporting live from JK news here
you guys all know this story hell yeah
he was who doesn't know this story this
is like [ __ ] crown free I was so
worried for you guy that texted you guys
see if you like legitimacy well because
I Louisa was worried it's cuz if jackass
had the [ __ ] Habib had and the
McGregor shirt I was gonna get jumped by
both sides of it why why can't you have
both on these people already drunk at
that so it's already like 9:30 10
o'clock and people you're not where
people are trying to [ __ ] with Bart no
but there's fights so you know the
minute that khabib jumped over yeah
there's a fight there all right then
Conor McGregor gets into a fight in the
cage to then instantly about three other
fights break out fights in the lobby
fights in the clubs two hours later like
Vegas was just rioting illness
- pop concert back in the 90s yeah it
was as if they were personal friends of
theirs or something like calm the [ __ ]
down you losers and I saw those fights
on the youtubes B worst fight I've ever
seen just about one white guy got
knocked out why there's a guy he comes
in right and it's obviously like all the
kabhi fans they look like could be fat
it look like five mins are you talking
about the fight that happened in the
floor are you talking about the one that
happened like one outside there's one in
the lobby
there's too many your will you're
referencing right now the guy that got
knocked out twice in the lobby okay so
this guy he there's a team of Nadine's
standing there this guy comes in and
he's all like talking [ __ ] he gets
kicked punched in the face he gets
knocked out right he goes off to the
side dr. Nadim look can do this fighting
some other dude and this guy jumps in
like France in like a fairy afraid for
some reason man who's just so [ __ ]
drunk you know like he had no idea
anything anything touched his face he
would have knocked out cuz he was so
[ __ ] drunk it was to that point where
his legs were stiff and his orange you
know that dude Brendon Schwab from
fighter and a kid he's mister Schwab's
ya know but he he called this out oh
yeah for sure he did yeah it was like
I'm not going to this Joe Rogan posted
this [ __ ] yeah I saw that one yeah and I
was like whoa how did I mean like when
you're close enough to to that world I
guess you know that behind the scenes
and how like real that [ __ ] is and I
just thought it was a publicity thing
that they were doing it was publicity
for McGregor it wasn't yeah I think from
the beginning I never felt like he was
publicity as soon as McGregor got
arrested for throwing a [ __ ] dolly
I'm like oh [ __ ] this beef is for me but
I also know that Connor is crazy and so
that anything that karna does I can
always view it as publicity because I
think he's a marketing genius yeah he
knows what's gonna get people going
what's gonna get people riled up I think
has enough lawyers around him where he
knows his boundaries khabib coming from
the villages of Dagestan I don't think
he understands when people talk [ __ ]
it's like afterwards it's a cool you
know good fight you know I don't think
he knew that that's what I think like in
the cage when Kobe was still [ __ ]
pissed his own hamidi seals like calm
down calm down but he talked about my
father my religion it goes yeah that's
just to promote the fight and then so I
think like so that was a real fight to
khabib to could be put on every every
press conference when they're like face
to face nose to nose you should see it
like honors like he's like putting on a
circus that could be just like mm-hmm
I will keel like I fight there as a
child it was weird because like because
you guys were down there you know and we
just were watching it from like the TV
screen and stuff it's kind of crazy
because you could see like intent so
like when I watched that match the first
thing I said was McGraw mimic Robert
MacGregor looks sloppy that's the first
thing I said he looked like he was not
ready for a fight he looked like he put
more into his promotion than he did the
fighting so I got worried right I was
like dude Habib is a [ __ ] monster and
on top of that he's oversized for his
weight class yeah so if you just think
about that in general he's gonna get
[ __ ] murdered so when I was watching
that [ __ ] if you guys watch the replay
you'll see a couple of Clips where
McGregor does this he goes hey man it's
only business he literally said that to
him and then went to Habib when they
were when they broke up on deals like
the second round he said it to Abebe he
goes it's only business so he even knew
like oh [ __ ] for real for real he goes
it's only business and the Habib goes he
goes yeah I guess so
meaning that he goes oh his only
business I don't [ __ ] think so I'm a
[ __ ] destroyed yeah he doesn't know
what that means no one else remember
when I was texting you and he was
pounding in the face I told you they
thought that it was McGregor talking
[ __ ] it was actually Habib and Habib was
saying to him he goes let's talk now
let's talk let's talk let's talk and
then the great was your shoulders that
did that it looked like sportman like
punches that was like some murdered yeah
that was like some gorilla like at like
the top rage level just battle
it was bad man
I saw the me where they did that whole
Hulk and oh yeah [ __ ] Dylan Denis was
talking [ __ ] on the outside of the cage
I wish I could hear that he basically
called that he called him a terrorist
attack
oh why would he do that I don't dillan
dadís is so [ __ ] stupid like I love
that Deus jiu-jitsu but he is out of his
[ __ ] mind he's like one of the worst
MMA fighters on earth his static game is
trash his ground game is great he's only
had one match and he's talking that much
[ __ ] wait so why daca veve jump and go
toward the train to jump kick him like
what was what was what what got him
going well Dylan Denis has been talking
with Dylan Danis thinks he's mcgregor
like straight up like he talks hella
[ __ ] he has this type of bravado but he
has no background for it so he's been
talking like mad [ __ ] towards a beam and
his team the whole time yeah and it's
nothing to do with them right so he kept
on calling him like a terrorist rat
throughout the whole thing and habib was
listening to it so he could hear it in
the second second or third round you
could see him look over at dadís cuz he
could hear what he's saying yeah and he
he just a little bit too overboard
things got a little hype and that's what
yeah I think that's completely uncalled
for
like for him to do it at that point cuz
we all know at least from our end right
like us here we know that it's all a
marketing ploy right like like they're
trying to sell tickets that's just what
McGregor does it's also a mind game that
he's doing but for this guy the fight
already started and to continue to do
that now that sounds like some fight but
you know that's actually very prevalent
in all sports though just don't [ __ ]
with the fight whenever like play but I
asked you Paul you ever see the free
throws everyone's going like this yeah
people going up and down the court
people are yelling at they're trying to
get into your fault like if you're if
you're like Lakers and Boston playing
Celtics everyone is talking mad [ __ ]
like it's pretty normal that's sure it's
pretty normal I just don't think khabib
understand it understood the American
arena because I think for him I see he's
been training for this since he was four
right
and he's been in [ __ ] and he's like I
think he thinks of like in Russia a
sportsman is equivalent to a gentleman
there's a way you conduct yourself and
it's not really sports entertainment out
there it's more like sports athlete
gentlemen you're a high part of society
over here you're sports entertainment so
I don't think he understood
the two so I think for him I think about
like how the MBA looks like versus
basketball in the Olympics looks like
it's yeah there's no [ __ ] it's like
that was awesome I mean you know walk
back so I think like he didn't
understand all that and all of that she
just got to his head he's pretty much
like [ __ ] it was it was pretty crazy
especially because like his teammates
came in and that dude SOT Connor behind
his head you know what I mean and so I
don't know who it was that he had an
altercation with but that guy swung at
Connor and then Connor countered him
boom even when he's tired he countered
it but that part is what's tight we're
like these guys they know how to fight
good like the skills just can't escape
like Connor was fighting one guy he gets
hit from the back
he immediately covers and pivots around
yeah I'm like dude time to becomes like
walk in yeah I was reading some [ __ ]
though that it Conners camp and everyone
isn't as calculated as people believe to
be because they're also like some ghetto
ass Irish kids that they wanted to like
load up the plane with a bunch of their
homies and like Rumble to like that they
had the intent to go in there to start
some [ __ ] like it was a lot of tension
so it wasn't like one group is like oh
we're just doing this for marketing and
whatever and just for me it's
disappointing because number one like
UFC had such a hard time getting off his
legs right so like even like Ferguson
said to himself that [ __ ] maniac he
was like he's trying to bring it to like
an Olympic level because people are
trying to bring mixed martial arts to an
Olympic level it's not gonna happen not
because of stuff like this it's not
going to happen you know but it also
sucks cuz like Dana White is one and
obviously his whole team right is
pushing for it to become something like
that but then at the same time the exact
same team is rewarding that type of
behavior because how many repercussions
in McGregor like I'm a big mcgregor fan
and I love them and whatever but um like
all that like he jumped the Octagon and
got in like Jose Jose Aldo's face right
like before that fight and and they had
that altercation but that got reported
he got a bonus cuz he's selling more to
keep people are [ __ ] done though so
people have been using that as an
argument
right feels like well didn't you see him
when he jumped over the cage and went to
Josie although he didn't touch him they
did it right because they both
understood that it's a market except
that's what I'm saying like like it got
up from that point it got up a little
bit more and like that's what I'm saying
like that that type of behavior kept
getting rewarded to the point now that
it's like you have to be that extreme
and that big yeah well that's the thing
to know but that's how boxing is -
boxing has that [ __ ] you talk about
Tyson he literally said I'm gonna [ __ ]
you in the ass till you [ __ ] love me
[ __ ] you have to be like this there is
that in other sports hildren yeah you
know and so there's like this sport is
so interesting tonight the reason why I
was disappointing to Habib is because
number one you [ __ ] him up number two
you are the good guy so the whole thing
was [ __ ] like the feds thought he was
like whatever but after he won people
were cheering for Habib so that means at
this point dude you're on the top and
now you have a little [ __ ] asterisk
against your name now and I hate that
because Habib is [ __ ] amazing yeah
like I think that's why I Daniel was
trying to core me we'll try to calm him
down as I brought like you've got this
you're good you're good you're good but
then because of that now people are
gonna hit a little tarnish on his record
now why are there's a lot of sanctions
that's gonna happen on oh yeah do the
Commission's gonna come after him dude
they're saying that they're considering
keeping the entire two million dollar
privilege you know what's crazy is like
they're in the fight like when we saw
khabib choked out Conor and then like
everyone's like [ __ ] I went the
impossible is happening and then like
the minute when he let go and he threw
the mouthpiece like no one was expecting
some crazy [ __ ] like that I were just
thinking okay cool yeah just this is a
regular UFC he climbs over and then
that's when I get all these goosebumps
all of them right now be them right now
because it's like witness seeing Mike
Tyson bike Holyfield's ear it's like be
it's like being there everyone did
because immediately we're all stood up
we're like what yeah we all so we're
like what the [ __ ] is going on and even
after the after Connor get sex courted a
kebede gets exported
Bruce Buffer comes out all awkward Lee
and behind Soho so that would
lightweight champion and then we're just
looking at each other are we supposed to
stay here like is Dana gonna make
as Rogen's gonna make a statement
everyone's looking at each other and
then of course all the conner fans are
[ __ ] pissed you're like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
everyone just [ __ ] you we see fights
breaking yeah it was very eloquent funky
[ __ ] you they have their Irish accent
and I'm like that's a TOEFL you meet and
they dim the lights and then we're like
you have not backwards could yeah if it
wants to be taken seriously as a sport
they have to stop conducting themselves
like WWE yeah like I was thinking about
your boxing statement and it's like
things like that didn't happen I think
in boxing till way later yeah like when
it became an Olympic sport when it was
all that like it was still I think it
was a level of gentleman and
sportsmanship and then after like pro
boxing and then like like when it became
more entertainment with the days of like
people like becoming characters in
boxing and then like becoming showman's
I think that's when it started going
crazy and that's also the difference
between Olympic boxing and pro boxing
yeah so that's why I like after if you
oh that's right yeah yeah yeah go into
Olympic boxing if you're already Olympic
is the highest level of amateur boxing
and then when you go pro that's when
they know it's sports entertainment and
all the showmanship comes in but when
you look at the matches it's almost like
Olympic boxing looks like fencing
everyone's quiet no one's cheering and
it's like almost boring and then you
have pro boxing where it's just way
crazier
[Music]